simplify 16x plus 14 minus the entire
expression 3x squared plus X minus 9 so
when you subtract an entire expression
this is the exact same thing as having
16x plus 14 and then you're adding the
opposite of this whole thing or you're
adding negative 1 you're adding negative
1 times 3x squared plus X minus 9 or
another way to think about is you can
distribute this negative sign along all
of those terms that's essentially what
we're about to do here we're just adding
the negative of this entire thing we're
adding the opposite of it so this first
part I'm not going to change it that's
still just 16x plus 14 but now I'm going
to distribute the negative sign here so
negative 1 times 3x squared is negative
3x squared negative 1 times positive x
is negative x because that's a positive
1 X negative 1 times negative 9 remember
you have to consider this negative right
over there that is part of the term
negative 1 times negative 9 is positive
9 negative times a negative is a
positive so then we have positive 9
and now we just have to combine like
terms so what's our highest degree term
here I like to write in that order if we
have only one x squared term second
degree term we only have one of those
let me write it over here negative 3x
squared and then what do we have in
terms of first degree terms of just an X
X to the first power well we have a 16x
and then from that we're going to
subtract an X subtract 1 X so 16x minus
One X is 15 X if you have 16 or
something and you subtract one of them
away you're going to have 15 of that
something and then finally you have 14
you could view that as 14 times X to the
0 or just 14 14 plus 9 they're both
constant terms or they're both being
multiplied by X to the 0 14 plus 9 is 23
23 and we're done negative 3x squared
plus 15 X plus 23